yeah not that hard to get 22 and a half
sacks no not that hard at all
uh that's why no one has ever gotten
more than 22 and a half sacks since they
started tracking
the statistic now remember it was 2001
michael strahan
got there courtesy of brett favre and i
don't care what
anyone will ever say about it that was a
gift
sack for michael strahan to let him
break the record
and it stood for 19 years now uh
who's the best bet chandler jones or
anyone else the best bet
to break the single season sack record
if anyone is going to break it this year
well you know i'm going with my aggie
mike that's easy von miller talked about
breaking the record last year
bradley chubb unfortunately got hurt
vaughn only ended up with eight sacks
and the new broncos defense i think he
understands the defense better
bradley chubs back if he stays healthy i
think vaughn's gonna have another
monster year he's only 31
years old only two seasons he hasn't had
a double digit sacks he's always around
there
there's a lot of candidates for this i
mean you look at nick bosa and josh
allen and joey bosa
and there's a ton of guys in the league
chandler jones is a great bet i think
he's
one of the most underrated players in
the nfl playing right now i think he's
got a shot to do it but there is a
reason that it hasn't been done since
2001 so i think it's
probably not going to happen this year
but i'm going to say if it does
happen my my money's going to be on von
miller to get it done
and von miller was a fascinating case
study last year of what happens when you
have a new defense when
your partner on the other side bradley
chubb who had a phenomenal rookie year
for the broncos in 2018 isn't there
because of a torn acl
and you're just pressing there was a
sense last year
that as each game went by without von
miller getting the sacks that he was
trying to get
he got more frustrated and i just like a
golfer who
keeps having bad round after bad round
after bad round
it just snowballs it gets inside your
head and the thing about trying to get a
sack
you get close to a sack all the time
there really is an
element of luck right a great pass
rusher is around the quarterback
a lot sometimes your teammate is the one
who gets the sack
sometimes the guy just gets rid of the
ball in time
something else happens but you get close
to getting the sack
a lot but but but things have to fall
your way
to get that sack and and i think that's
what is one of the key ingredients
for setting the record shireen you have
to be able
to get lucky you can do everything right
and if you're just not lucky
you're going to have 12 or 13 sacks even
though if you'd been lucky you could
have had 25.
or have brett favre take a dive i mean
it's
bad brett favre's not around
what von miller needs to do is befriend
multiple quarterbacks preferably in the
division so he plays them twice per year
i don't think patrick holmes is going to
go along with it but make some friends
send them send send them some i don't
know what he does with his chickens i
assume that you know they
whether it's eggs or whether it's
chicken meat either way he's got his
chicken farm do something suck up to the
quarterbacks you're gonna play
especially
if you start racking up the sacks look
at the schedule and and try to make some
friends with somebody who you're going
to be playing late in the season all
right
who winds up with the career
wait was that your guess too i mean did
you say von miller are you saying
somebody else
uh you know i'm on a big daniel hunter
kick just because i don't think he gets
enough respect pft bingo i think that's
the lower right square
but in part because people can't
pronounce his name but also in part
because he is
just kind of a quiet soft-spoken guy who
has been in the shadows behind everson
griffin in minnesota
this is his year to come into his own
and i think that he could wreak havoc
not that he's going to get 22 and a half
but i think he could be up there with
the leaders this year all right who
winds up
with the career passing touchdown record
right now drew brees and tom brady
are neck and neck sort of breezes at 5
47 brady's at 5 41.
who's going to have it when it's all
said and done
well drew brees considered retirement
after last season tom brady did not
consider retirement after last season as
we said
in the last segment we're going to find
out if tom brady has his legs still that
coming up in the season with the weapons
he has but i love
the weapons that he has and i think he's
going to have a lot of touchdowns this
season
and and i think he's going to continue
his career so i think he's going to
outlast drew brees which makes me
think that tom brady is going to end up
with the record although brees might
want to keep going
so that he beats tom brady in that
record and retires with that record but
i'm going with tom brady in this one
just simply because i think he outlasts
drew brees i think he's going to play
longer
i really do believe this is the last
year for drew brees
in new orleans in part because
he wants it to be and in part because
others may want it to be who are in the
organization but you just get the sense
that's the direction it's moving in
they want to see what they have in
taysom hill they want to move on the
deep ball isn't there and
he said some things interesting earlier
this week about
things he's done in the off season to
try to improve his deep ball i just
don't think it's something you can just
work extra hard on you either have it or
you don't so i agree with you
i think tom brady is going to last
longer and i don't think the gap is
going to be so big
that brady won't be able to overcome it
when uh brees has retired all right
michael thomas who set the record last
year for single season receptions
with 149 he has said
he can break that record this year so
the over under for michael thomas
149.5 are you over or are you
under i'm absolutely
under i mean we only saw the 149 last
year for the first time ever
he had 125 the year before that i mean
he's certainly capable of having a lot
of catches he's also had
good injury luck which we know can
change and we don't know how
how long this season is going to last
how many games they're going to play so
there's a lot of factors to me that's
going to keep that number
under 149 this season we also don't know
about drew brees's arm how much he has
left in it can he still get the ball to
michael thomas or how much is taysom
hill going to play
there's a lot of questions to me on on
michael thomas and how many catches he's
going to end up with look he's one of
the best receivers
in football and he's going to catch
everything around him but i think it's
going to be under 149 and a half
well he's going to have that blazing red
dot this year every time a defense gets
ready to play him the vikings were able
to neutralize him to a certain extent in
the playoff game that film is going to
be instructive on defenses on how to
shut him down and may not that they not
that you can
how he can slow him down emmanuel
sanders is there now he's going to get
his share of balls
i just don't think it's a good idea to
have one guy catching that many passes
you need to spread it around a little
bit more i'm going to go under and i
think it's better for the saints
if it is under even though michael
thomas i still think one of the finest
receivers
in the game all right last one best bet
to be the first
nfl 2 000 yard receiver last year amari
cooper told me with a straight face he
was going for 2
000 yards and look this is the time of
year where everybody has these
superlatives these lofty goals
is there someone that can be the first
one ever calvin johnson did 1964
eight years ago is there someone who can
get to 2000
i think it's still a tough record tough
record to come by and i don't think it's
going to be done this year but
i think michael thomas is is probably
the best bet to do that simply because
he has so many chances he gets so many
balls and and he
he gets yards off those well i mean
obviously the more balls you have the
more yards you can come up with and when
you look at him he is the lead receiver
on that team he's going to get a lot of
chances they don't have a ton of weapons
when when you look at deandre hopkins
and you look at all the weapons that
kyler murray is going to have i think
they're going to spread the ball around
and i think deandre hopkins numbers
might even come down
uh this year and julio jones obviously
has calvin ridley as you guys discussed
the number two receivers yesterday
so to me michael thomas is the number
one guy the go-to guy is going to get a
lot of receptions has a chance to get a
lot of yards but i don't think it's
going to be done
if calvin johnson couldn't do it in his
prime
i i can't imagine that there's anyone
currently in the league who can get
there
especially when we consider that
arbitrary
unrelenting possibility that any given
sunday or monday or thursday of the 16
games of the season the guy who's on
track
to get to 2 000 yards can't play because
he's on the covet 19 list
so to me that that's even if there was
somebody who i thought had a chance
to get to 2000 i'd be nervous about
saying that i really think it can be
done because
we don't know we don't even know there's
gonna be a season i we hope there is
but 2 000 yards you're not going to get
2000 yards in 10 games
you're going to get 2 000 yards in 16
games and uh until we know there's going
to be 16 games it's impossible to even
think about those kind of records all
right
let's take a break despite several
conferences announcing their schedules
it wasn't all
optimism this week for college football
we'll explain next where things stand
as the college game possibly teeters on
the brink more pft live right after this
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights
from nbc sports